this is Zoe Watts doing what she loved a
talented gymnast and trampolinist she
had such a promising future ahead of her
but she struggled with anorexia and
mental health problems and took her own
life when she was just 19 years old
so so talented yeah she was really good
her father says post she viewed on
social media encouraged her to self-harm
they're a very graphical content of
young girls with slashes all over their
arms and blood dripping off
uh boasting about it and saying that
this is great you know almost like
um uh as if it's as if it's something
that they should follow there's been
outcry following another tragedy 14 year
old Molly Russell was found dead in her
bedroom after viewing content on social
media related to suicide and self-harm
there are now plans to make online posts
that encourage people to hurt themselves
illegal
Keith Watts says it's progress but he
worries about how harmful posts would be
policed are we going to lock up young
children because I can tell you now a
lot of the children that are actually a
lot of the content that's being pushed
around is from children anyway
uh you know 15 16 17 year old children
the social media Giants are the ones
that really need to get to grips with
this the government says social media
firms can no longer be silent bystanders
and could face fines some within the
tech industry feel the data already
collected for targeted advertising
should be used much more proactively
they can track all this information they
know all this information they should do
a bit more about you know providing more
like positive data to that to that
person in in a way which it doesn't
escalate or go for and they can detect
this information earlier on
Keith still has a lot of questions
including who will keep track of this
dangerous content but he is optimistic
although this bill comes too late for
Zoe he desperately hopes other young
people will get the protection online
that she never had
Becky Cottrell Sky News high Wiccan
and just to remind you if you've been
affected by that story and you want to
talk to someone you can always call the
Samaritans for free on 116 123 or you
can email them Joe
samaritans.org the address there for you